an off-duty Alaska Airlines Captain
tried to shut down the engines while in
the jump seat of a plane on
Sunday uh wait go down let's read that
followup Joseph David Emerson 44 has
been a pilot for over 20 years he's
scheduled to be ar4 is part of his
name yeah he's the 44th sorry that was
so bad he's been a pilot for over 20
years he's scheduled to be arraigned
Tuesday on 83 charges of attempted
murder 83 charges of reckless
endangerment and one charge of
endangering an aircraft he is also
expected to be charged in federal court
with inter interference with flight crew
members and
attendants according to court documents
Emerson told investigators he was having
a nervous breakdown hadn't slept in 40
hours and was
dehydrated oh so this and now they now
he's saying he was on
mushrooms during the incident but wait
he wasn't flying the plane right he was
in the jump seat what's the jump seat um
is that the co-pilot or is that like
behind yeah so he got up and was like
and tried to shut up let me in there
yeah yeah oh oh so he went up there and
probably tickled the guy that was flying
the plane to distract him and leaned
over and tried to shut off the engines
oh oops yeah yeah yeah bro what is this
button stop stop Daniel
stop
what you just
do nothing
stop that's crazy man so he just in the
jump seat tripping balls tripping balls
hadn't slept in 40 hours just [__] yo
yeah yeah n you know this is a this is
big Aviation trying to hide that they
don't [__] pay their pilots well
there apparently there's like a huge
Mental Health crisis among Pilots right
now which is not [__] info that I
want to know you
know it's extremely scary yeah like
apparently a lot apparently this is what
I was one of my friends was
saying if
you even express that you're having
troubles with your mental mental health
as a pilot you lose the ability to
fly like right away but there's no
support services for dealing with
depression and stuff like that like they
just take away your life
so they all hide it that's good and they
act like they're fine that's good and
then it leads to [__] like this so
that's why Pilots are you know coked out
and slamming drinks at the bar and yeah
pretty much that's good man wait go back
to
that American Pilots sound the alarm on
Mental Health after off duty Alaska
Airlines pilot Joseph Emerson tries to
shut down planes engines while high on
magic mushrooms what do you think he was
seeing I I think this guy's like a
special case what do you you think he
was seeing when he was tripping that
made him want to shut the plane down
look at look at him is that bro right
there scroll up he looks like he's
tripping still he don't know where the
hell he's at yeah seriously so are we
still on the plane yeah I'm S I don't
know these controls I'm sorry
I where are we yeah part of the reason
we may be seeing more near misses is
because as an industry we now have a
much younger Workforce that does not
have the benefits of having decades
worth of experience
that's really good yeah this whole like
near misses thing is pretty [__]
horrifying well that also makes me think
about when I was flying back
from New Zealand home and the plane
started pitching and going through crazy
Motions like through
turbulence and Alina is thinking these
are our final
moments [__] when we go to
land someone goes let's hear it for our
young co-pilot here with his first uh
you know transatlantic flight and people
start clapping I said to myself is the
last thing I want to hear is hey give it
up for my boy who just flew us through
that yeah like he's 23 he's young yeah
also first time you don't want to hear
that at all no you want to hear give it
up for the veteran this is his last
flight yeah actually no you don't want
to hear
that yeah that's when it starts to
that's when you hear the engines go e
yeah yeah give it up for our veteran
this is his last flight I won't do it
anymore
I this is his last flight and also all
of
ours in a safety report filed last year
one said controllers are making mistakes
left and right fatigue is Extreme the
margin for safety has eroded tenfold
morale is Rock Bottom I catch myself
taking risks and shortcuts I normally
would never take that's an air traffic
controller oh yeah air traffic controll
rollers are like wait go go down isn't
that like the number one most stressful
job or some [__] Staffing shortages also
exacerbates masturbate sorry exacerbate
Pilots mental health issues and looming
over any problems of fear that if they
don't that if they report their concerns
they could lose their
wings oh jeez that's what the that's
what the 133% of Pilots meet the
criteria for depression and 4% reported
suicidal dots that's good so
let's do the math on that no let's not
four out of every 100
flights that guy is walking on the plane
thinking this is
it [__] that gave me the worst
feeling
sorry Jesus Christ well you know that
was a KS and he slept yeah that's
good right
yeah that's so scary of it's just
someone walking through his Pilot staff
being like now no one in this room would
be sad would
they everyone's happy let's see those
Smiles come on let's see those teeth
they're
all that's right cuz we're all happy to
fly yeah right yeah so that that's good
yeah that's really awesome that the
airline industry really cares about
safety I mean bro you you feel it now on
planes what all the flight attendants
they're just at their
last they have no [__] left yeah I know
it's true they really don't they don't I
also heard they don't get paid until the
plane is in the
air what do you mean that's officially
when they're on the clock oh really yeah
huh that's that's my understanding
huh dude coming back from Austin our
flight got delayed they said it was
because the defroster was was not
working on the window and I was
chuckling it how bad that could have
they're just in the sky and they're like
oh there's some
[__] just completely foged
up
uh I guess we're just going to do it by
feel then yeah all right feel it out we
can feel it out yeah we can feel the
we'll feel the Run yeah we'll feel the
runway yeah yeah should be about right
here ah [__] go a little lower right
here all right at we're going to attempt
this with low visual just uh give us
some
guidance uh American 387 you're flying a
little sorry sorry dark asck sorry sorry
sorry all of this is [__] scary yeah
dude all of this sucks ass this
conversation [__] sucks I got to get
on a flight next week yeah
sucks scary as hell can we Campa yeah
that's good Luke yeah yeah thanks thanks
for
that